le type d'agriculture enfin je crois que
voilà michael c'est un bon exemple sur
une ferme de 45 ha 180 mille litres de
lait ya deux personnes qui travaillent
donc effectivement une densité d'actifs
qui est importante c'est ce type de
ferme
on cherche à promouvoir ce que vous
pensez aussi aux territoires
ah oui tout à fait sur les territoires
groupe c'est vrai que si je reprends
l'exemple de michael on est aussi
content de le voir administrateur d'une
coopérative laitière en tant que hors
cadre familial c'est vrai que forcément
il apporte dans la coopérative aussi
avoir un petit peu nouveau pour ça
serait parti du dynamisme local
je vais vous poser la question qu'est ce
qui selon vous fait montre que michael
entre michel et mickaël c'est une
transmission réussie bien sûr pas toutes
façons ils l'expriment
il exprime très très bien quoi joue pas
aussi bien michel que michael la façon
dont ils l'expriment
c'est très net on sent qu'il ya du vécu
derrière c'est pas c'est pas de la
communication quand il ya un vrai vécu
et après il ya des données des données
effectivement objective de fait que
mickaël sincère tout seul hic trois ans
après on fait l'installation de sa femme
soit soit possible c'est un signe
les résultats économiques je parle c'est
michel qui les évoqué tout à la peau
s'il continue à beaucoup échangé les
résultats économiques sont très bons sur
la ferme
on l'a vu on sort de la grange là où il
ya encore malgré ces chiffres la
dernière et encore deux fois et de
qualité lanuf oil bien vert en réserve
c'est le signe que effectivement il ya
une maîtrise aussi technique donc
économique de la femme qu est ce que le
fait qu'ils soient aussi membre actif de
diverses associations ça montre son
intégration
oui moi je suis enfin je suis épaté quoi
c'est à dire que quelqu'un qui arrive
qui prend en charge une somme comme
celle ci c'est nouveau il ya un gros
travail à faire en installation et qui
trouve le temps de s'investir dans des
structures comme la coopérative laitière
une association dont la cote autour de
comptabilité le fait qu'il a envie de
travailler en collectif
à côté de sa ferme c'est sait comment ça
c'est bien